the first season we i had a major crush
on
jen um i and
yeah and i think it was we both
reciprocate uh
yeah you heard that right david
schwimmer and jennifer aniston
had crushes on each other in real life
i'm sorry that's all the time we have no
kidding i'm sorry
okay go on the long-awaited friends the
reunion special
dropped on hbo max thursday and the
former co-stars who shared an on-screen
romance in the hit 90s sitcom
as ross geller and rachel green
basically
lately i've uh
i've sort of had feelings for you
admitted that
all that on-screen heat translated
off-screen too
after the night's host james corden
asked them this
you're all young hot
good-looking successful actors
and it's inconceivable to me that there
weren't
perhaps off-screen romances
i mean david yeah
yeah i mean the the first season yeah
the first season
we i had a major crush on jen
um i and yeah and i think
we both said um who else is shook
it's unexplainable yeah and it didn't
stop there
at some point we were both crushing hard
on each other but
it was like two ships passing because
one of us was always in a relationship
so
and we never crossed that boundary you
know we
respected that and but we both
okay so the two never actually hooked up
behind the scenes
but their cast mates were totally in on
their secret crush
i thought back on the very first year or
two you know when we have
breaks from rehearsal like there were
moments we would like
cuddle on a couch or something
and i'm thinking how did not everyone
know we had we're crushing on each other
we knew we knew we knew for sure and the
chemistry didn't stop with jen and david
the cast was friends on camera and off
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
and it was without question et recently
sat down with the cast to talk about the
highly anticipated reunion
and they dished on their tight-knit bond
even decades later
there was never competition there was
never if there was ever a conflict it
was
instantly addressed and handled no
eggshells
it was just something we really grew
close as a family and part of the reason
was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
um we really we really got close because
of
that experience too but back to ross and
rachel
remember that steamy first kiss in the
coffee house
jen recalled a combo she had with david
before they shot that on-screen smooch
i remember saying one time to david it's
gonna be such a bummer if the first time
you and i actually kiss is gonna be on
national
television sure enough
first time we kissed was in that coffee
shop
so we just channeled all of our
adoration and love for each other into
ross and rachel and just in case that
wasn't enough nostalgia for you
it's not like i didn't i didn't try
rachel but things got in the way you
know like
like italian guys or ex-fiancees or
or or italian guys hey
there was one italian guy okay and do
you
even have a point jen and david sat
around the table
with their cast mates and reenacted that
famous scene
the door flies open ross rushes in grabs
her
and they kiss
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yay